how to handle criticism from little man
I'm working on a new online project
something that I'm really excited about
something I think will help a lot of
people build way better businesses and
believe in themselves more that's what
I'm all about I'm really excited about
this project
now little man gets a hold of it he sees
it and he says this will never work and
he writes in to me I want to read this
word for this is what he writes in
please tell me you actually understand
how the internet works let me breathe
for a second here okay the criticism is
important ok criticism could help make
you better can help make you stronger
but you have to pay attention to who is
criticizing you and the kind of feedback
that you're getting I see entrepreneurs
as gladiators ok we wake up every day
and we go to fight for a business we go
to fight for our dreams and we risk
humiliation failure ridicule
embarrassment from all of people
watching us we're in the ring and
they're all in the stands and that's
where little man sits little man sits
there eating this popcorn laughing at
you joking at you really killing you
throwing stuff at you but he's too
afraid to come down from in the stands
and get in the ring you're the gladiator
and you can't let little man's opinions
and doubt hold you back
why don't I compare okay we're talking
about the Internet me versus little man
I've had 20 million people visit my
website little man's website maybe a
thousand
it's an old looking site I've got two
hundred thousand Twitter followers
little man a couple thousand I've got a
million views on YouTube little man a
couple thousand little man doesn't know
what he's talking about and this is the
danger that entrepreneurs run into
because people are going to criticize
you and it's hard accepting criticism
it's hard when people tell you that
you're not
good enough but you have to look at
who's telling you this because if it's
little man who's done nothing important
himself then pay him no mind
now if the founders of Google are the
founders of Twitter or people I look up
to like Gary Vee they write to me and
say tell me you know how the internet
works and they tell me here's what you
need to do to get better then I'm gonna
pay attention to them because they're
gladiators with me they know what
they're talking about and often those
guys are gonna give you constructive
criticism and direct feedback instead of
just hating on your idea I'm telling you
all the reasons why it's not gonna work
out don't pay attention to little man
don't pay attention to his ideas his
feedback because it's only gonna tear
you down believe in yourself and what
you're doing because it's important
believe for those of you watching the
video you like it give it a thumbs up it
always always want to do more leave a
comment below and let me know what you
think you have a question put it below
make a video response and if you want to
see more videos like this you can
subscribe to the channel by clicking on
my face thank you so much and I'll see
you soon